there's a dirty little secret almost
every country's keeping except it's not
that little in many cases a nation's
armed forces are its biggest single
emitter of greenhouse gases but how big
is secret that's allowed under both the
kyoto and paris climate agreements both
deals have exempted military forces
based on the argument that adversaries
could deduce strategy using emissions
data but with climate catastrophes on
the rise environmental activists insist
any credible carbon reduction plan must
include these hidden figures the size of
the fuel use dependency is huge and
they've got a huge supply chain so
obviously it's going to make a big
difference if they're involved or not
involved in these emission reduction
targets lindsay cattrell is a researcher
at the climate and environment
observatory it's one of the groups that
have just created a website tracking
what little information countries have
voluntarily revealed about military
emissions worldwide the united states
with the world's highest military
spending is shown as having very
significant under-reporting but brown
university's cost of war project using
public data estimates the u.s armed
forces emit more than many
industrialized countries including
sweden or portugal
lindsey cattrell hopes the more the new
website publishes the more the public
will push for action then the argument
will be there that more needs to be done
and targets need to be set the european
union's net zero plan does not even
mention much less mitigate military
emissions but at nato no less than
secretary general jen stoltenberg is
trying to green the alliance for nato's
own sake as well as the planets these
days many countries militaries are
increasingly forced to fight natural
disasters stoltenberg is the first nato
chief to appear at a climate summit he
underscored that nato leaders agreed in
june to the first step in voluntary
reductions develop a methodology a
framework an agreed mapping a structure
to count military missions former
estonian defense minister rijeras is
skeptical allied governments share
stoltenberg's enthusiasm i don't think
it is possible
because then we should
be sure that the adversary will do the
same thing i mean and that would not
happen for sure or not
russia no no russian or china would
would consider that as a priority nato's
james apatherai disagrees and is helping
craft a plan to present at the
alliance's summit next year
green
is going to be painted across this
entire innovation ecosystem to see if we
can't help come up with technological
solutions
yes to reduce greenhouse gas emissions
but also to help our forces operate in
what will be a more difficult weather
environment he says there's growing
interest even in china and russia in how
armed forces can battle climate change
as the world worries together over
shared ecosystems such as the arctic the
concerns of environmentalists and
military strategists may finally be
converging but there's a long way to go
and scientists warn the time we have to
get there is already almost up
indeed dw's terry schultz who filed that
report she joins me now from brussels
good evening to you terry
one study puts the u.s military and not
the u.s is just its military somewhere
between 47th and 55th biggest emitter of
greenhouse gases in the world making a
military be a moth like that go green
starting at the pentagon seems almost as
difficult as getting an agreement at
those talks in glasgow
i don't think it's that difficult
because the pentagon has acknowledged
for years that climate change is a risk
multiplier for it in in so many ways
interestingly brent even under the trump
administration
where you had the president denying
climate change uh the pentagon quietly
continued its plans for how to
i would say maybe green its military is
a little bit too optimistic at this
point but but to optimize the ways that
it could cut back on climate change so
uh the pentagon has had this on its
radar for many years it's just as you
said a behemoth and it takes a long time
to change and the us military has
usually been or traditionally been where
new technologies are first applied
can it be the same for for green
technologies i mean can't the the
military benefit from
a green economy
absolutely it can and it will be one of
the places where green technology is is
definitely born and is being born at the
moment and certainly uh civil military
partnerships are going to be you know
the real innovators and nato as you
heard james and pather i say is also
working on um sort of in innovation
central so that it could be spread among
the allies but you know this this truly
will be um necessary for the pentagon
and and and for all militaries around
the world and it requires a real mindset
change because until recent years they
were working mostly on combating the
effects of climate change on their
operations changing the uniforms that
that
soldiers wore changing the way that
tanks
you know could roll through really
desertified
regions and now they're very much
looking at changing the factors that
cause
uh cause climate change as well as
adapting to to those effects
and what about natives plan i mean
stoltenberg
will he be able to push through his
agenda i mean he really is a 21st
century
military figure the way he is you know
pushing
a green agenda as well isn't he
he's a very interesting figure to take
this forward and he will give it and ten
percent for sure uh he he actually was a
u.n climate envoy back in the day as you
saw in my piece in 1997 when the kyoto
protocol gave militaries this exemption
so he was at that summit when militaries
were said okay you can keep emissions
quiet because we accept your argument
that perhaps you know too much about
your movements and and your equipment
could be discerned by by giving that
data and stoltenberg says openly time's
up for that we cannot live that way
anymore he acknowledges he continues to
acknowledge that you don't have to make
it public but he told me personally
we can take that data we can we can get
in the emissions data at nato and we can
help countries reduce but brent i also
talked to allies after the nato climate
plan was passed and and they sort of
rolled their eyes and said you know it's
going to be voluntary and we don't have
to do it and some of us aren't going to
do it so he may not get all 30 allies on
board but even having a methodology by
which they could count their admissions
will be a big step
terry schultz as always terry thank you
you